[Music]
hello everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
back to funding go in the movie guide my
very first one for 2018 and I want to
start with a film that's in theaters
which just won the Golden Globe Award
for Best Foreign Language Film in the
fade this is a German film directed by
Fatih akin starring Diane Kruger as a
woman whose life falls apart after her
husband and son are killed in a bomb
attack and she wants to find out who did
it
plus he's been in twist off from the
money I find by a Muslim
the office in the other firm you go to
dr. Diane Kruger is absolutely
remarkable in this movie in the fade
deals with prejudice terrorism and
intense grief it's part of motional
drama part courtroom procedural and then
part revenge thriller you can see in the
fade in limited theaters right now now
let's go to a mysterious film starring
Alex Pettyfer and James frites and
Jackson called the strange ones they
fled brothers who are travelling across
America on a road trip and all we know
is that there was a devastating fire in
their past and the brothers may not be
telling the truth
sound confusing well the lack of
information is actually what sets up
this unsettling mood which pervades
throughout the entire film not the
season for that yet we're just doing
some target practice
it's low-budget but is shot quite
beautifully and the star of the film is
definitely young James frites and
Jackson given the haziness of what's
real versus what's not real the film
might not hold together for you the
entire time but it's a really well-made
indie thriller and it has an extremely
creepy opening sequence that is worth
that ticket price alone remember
it's not real fire it's all in your head
you can catch the strange ones in select
theaters right now I need you to answer
honestly what were you two doing out
there in the forest
and a great little indie you can see on
video on-demand on Fandango now is
called blame this is directed by and
starring Queen Shepard who plays Abigail
a high school student who's a bit of a
loner and she gets bullied by other
girls like Melissa this bullying gets
worse when Abigail is cast as the lead
in the school play The Crucible
and she was given that role by the new
drama teacher played by Chris Messina
Abigail Williams this is the villain of
the play it's a great great great part
it's a difficult part anyone want to try
to tackle that I'm gonna have to go with
the namesake Abigail and things get a
little hazy between student and teacher
this is a cracker of a low-budget indie
I love the way the story in real life
parallels the story of the play The
Crucible with ideas of women as witches
and witch hunts and women getting blamed
for everything and it explores that grey
area between innocence and guilt it also
puts the audience in the position of
judging Abigail particularly when it
comes to her actions towards her teacher
this is a really strong feature film
debut for 22 year old Quinn Shepherd who
also co-wrote the film I cannot wait to
see what she does next and you should
try to catch blame on Fandango now right
this moment dude oh my god tell me how
to talk to you and these without access
of some pedophile you really not see the
Jesus
and also if you watch the Golden Globe
Awards and now you want to see some of
the movies that were nominated look out
for the list on Fandango now there's
Dunkirk let's get out this baby driver
plus the TV series - I'm Alicia Malone
you can catch me on Twitter at Alicia
Malone and in the comments below I want
to know what you thought about the
Golden Globe Awards was there a film
that you wish won more than it did I'll
see you soon bye
[Music]